jours en afghanistan à la cour pénale
internationale a décidé de relancer son
enquête sur les crimes de guerre
présumés dans le pays problème la cpi ne
prendra pas en compte les actes commis
par des américains sur le sol afghan
cette décision fait polémique notamment
après qu'un bombardement à partir d'un
drone américain a tué dix civils dont
sept enfants des familles des victimes
demandent toujours que justice soit
faite les précisions du correspondant
d'ayrté international lamoura de gaz y
est presque hausse
ce qui a provoqué un tel scandale et une
telle fureur parmi les militants et les
organisations des droits de l'homme
c'est que la cpi dit en fait nous
n'avons ni le temps ni les moyens
d'enquêter sur les milliers de victimes
civiles confirmé causés par les états
unis et l'armée afghanes le procureur
dit aux criminels de guerre du monde
entier que la stratégie américaine
consistant à retarder et à intimider
fonctionne cela donne raison également à
l'une des principales critiques visant
la cpi qu'elle ne prend des mesures que
contre des individus ou des nations
politiquement plus faibles tout en
donnant carte blanche aux puissances
occidentales en des priorisant l'enquète
sur les américains et les anciennes
forces de sécurité nationale de
l'afghanistan le procureur de la cpi
leur évite honteusement la prison vaut
peuvent adopter une kate nash toutes les
personnes qui ont été kidnappé et
torturé dans des bases afghanes ou dans
des bases secrètes de la cia en
afghanistan
10 le fait que nous en soyons arrivés là
est dû à des tactiques de gangsters car
initialement la cpi a annoncé qu'elle
enquêterait sur le rôle de chacun dans
tout crime de guerre potentiel commis en
afghanistan ce qui a provoqué une énorme
campagne de pressions de la part des
états unis ces derniers menaçant et
sanctionnant des responsables de la cpi
le moment de la décision de la cpi de
l'annonce n'aurait pas pu être plus mal
choisi la presse internationale ainsi
que le gouvernement américain sont
encore sous le choc des retombées de la
dernière attaque de drone de la guerre
en afghanistan le pentagone mène frappes
de drones à kaboul ciblant un véhicule
présumé de des shows khorassan le
propriétaire de la voiture s'avère être
un civil travaillant pour un groupe
d'être basé aux états unis
la frappe là dessus et lui ainsi que
neuf membres de sa famille dont sept
enfants et
d'autres causes n révélé une cage aussi
jacques ameye voix katiu une frappe de
drone qui a fait dix victimes civiles
nous sommes restés en contact avec leurs
proches et les seules excuses qu'ils ont
entendues ont été prononcées à la
télévision et si les états unis le
pentagone qualifie la mort de dix de
leurs proches d' erreur tragique il
affirme en même temps qu aucune mesure
disciplinaire ne sera appliquée et cela
leur fait comprendre que si leurs pertes
n'a pas été infligée par les talibans ou
des sèches et bien c'est qu'ils n'ont
pas eu de chance
je dirai à la cpi que nous demandons
justice depuis plus d'un mois maintenant
nous avons souffert personne ne nous a
posé de questions ou aider il faut que
la justice soit rendue dans les plus
brefs délais je demande aux américains
et à d'autres personnes dans le monde
qui permettent à l'armée américaine de
bombarder des civils innocents dans
n'importe quelle partie du monde que
cela cesse une fois pour toutes il ne
faut plus de meurtres de femmes et
d'enfants innocents
le pentagone a présenté des excuses de
toutes sortes et beaucoup d'entre elles
ont été reprises dans la presse pour
expliquer pourquoi il s'agissait d'une
erreur commise de bonne foi mais
prétendent avoir tiré la leçon de cette
terrible tragédie mais beaucoup de gens
ont du mal à y croire étant donné que
cette tragédie est survenue après vingt
ans de présence américaine en
afghanistan
après que tant de frappes de drones
similaires ont mal tourné
je continuerai exigé que chaque personne
ayant commis un crime ici soient
condamnés et punis conformément à la loi
il est injuste qu'une personne comme est
un crime et qu'une autre personne soit
traduites devant le tribunal pour
répondre de ce crime c'est le criminel
qui doit être puni il ne faut pas de
bouc émissaire si les américains
commettent un crime ils doivent être
traduits en justice ils doivent rendre
des comptes pour leurs actes ce sont les
américains qui ont attaqué notre maison
pas les talibans il est illogique que ce
soit aux talibans de répondre de cette
attaque les drones armés américains
continuent de bourdonner dans l'espace
aérien de l'afghanistan les américains
affirmant qu'ils n'ont pas besoin et ne
prévoit pas de demander d'autorisation
afghanes pour mener des frappes
aériennes en afghanistan façon de
rappeler à tout le monde personne dans
l'administration maiden ou au pentagone
a été licencié n'a démissionné ou n'a
l'intention de partir à la suite de ce
que beaucoup décrivent comme le fiasco
du retrait américain d'afghanistan